e
good
morning it being 9:00 a.m. I'd like to
call the order this organizational
meeting the Capital project overview
committee and I'd like to recognize
Senator Lang for motion please I move
that we nominate the uh rep miltz as
chair motion's been made and
seconded we'll do a Voice vote on this
all in favor say I opposed motion
carries I would like to make a motion
right now uh I nominate for vice chair
Senator Mark mcon
second motion's been made and seconded
we are not going to be able to act on
this today because Senator mcy is not
here to accept it formally so we will uh
carry that over to the next
meeting having said that I would like to
make a motion to nominate Mike Edgar as
clerk motion's been made and seconded
clerk item one is not completed item two
committee
orientation should have in front of
you
procedures informational we also
have the capap
251 revised statutes to the capital
committee informational does anything
have to be voted on representative I
mean Mr Shan uh just to accept the the
um procedure procedures of the committee
you should just adopt that so the just
for a kind of a quick overview for the
new members of the committee um the
organization uh procedures guidelines
and procedures basically address two
issues one is how items come to the
committee from the agencies telling the
agencies that they need to provide our
office you know within two weeks of the
meeting with the materials that they
want to come before this meeting if
there's a need for a late item that they
need to make a request to the chair the
second portion of this is um two year in
the last budget the capital um budget
overview committee was changed the
capital project overview committee and
as part of that there's a quarterly
report report that's um provided to this
committee through dep Department of
administrative services and this
committee put some guard rails up for
lack of a a better term in terms of what
you want capital projects to be worth
before they get included on this report
so that's what these guidelines are um
intended to provide the committee as
well as the agencies so that you didn't
end up with $50,000 projects being
reported on a quarterly basis when you
didn't really need need or want them
before you
move to accept
second motion's been made and seconded
all those in favor say I I
opposed motion
carries moving right along the
acceptance of minutes of the November
12th
minutes motion has been made I will
second that
any corrections
concerns saying none all those in favor
say I I opposed not not abstained
numbers of
obained do you have those abstentions
I've got Senator Waters representative
ER Edgar and wer Edgar and
you under old business none under new
business
none under miscellaneous none this is
starting to be my favorite committee so
far I've ever been
on informational also in the package you
have
c252 from the uh Department of
administrative Services the quarterly
capital budget project report for the
2024 m Mr Shay help us um so this is the
corly report that we I just referenced
in terms of the organizational materials
so the department of administrative
Services compiles all the capital
projects around the state um within the
limit guidance of the procedures you
just adopted you'll see the the long 8
and 1 half by 14 page that would be
considered the old capital budget report
that you used to get at the last couple
pages are the new projects that were
included when this became a capital
project overview and then the large
pages in the back are all dot projects
that are a million dollars or more that
um they're now reporting I'd like to um
just let the committee know as well that
the governor's trailer Bill does propose
to make this a annual report versus a
quarterly report so um just be aware of
that because it will be in house bill to
it if the committee has some feelings
related to that they should um probably
let Finance members know in the house or
in the Senate if it passes the
house any
questions Senator Waters please thank
you Mr chairman I I wondered if I might
just ask a couple questions about some
projects and if you could answer me
later or or now um I wondered uh what
the status was of the be the rebid for
agriculture and
um I also would if you could get an
update on the construction of the um
woodworking facility at the state
prison and
um
then
uh for the
um the pier projects at Peas the one was
supposed to be done in February and I I
just I don't think I'd seen that but if
you could just check on both the
projects the peas
projects um and for the prison what was
the question for that one well are what
is the status of those they were
supposed to be done I haven't heard if
they're done or not of the not the pe's
the prison you mentioned the prison
project the the prison W woodworking um
what what is the status of that oh The
Woodworking got it for for the women's
facility facility for the
construction and um the last one uh I
mean I can call do but I was curious
about the general solvent Bridge removal
if they have any kind of scheduling or
of rfps or anything on that
one I I will get the information and
then I'll send an email to the full
committee as to what I've gotten from
each of the agencies Mr chairman by
welome any other questions Senator Lang
so I I'm interested in the projects that
are all on hold what's going to happen
next like I'm looking at one for
do um about a roof or something about a
Grant application it's on page uh no
page numbers on this thing but anyway um
it's a $4 million ask that was forwarded
the balance is forward the balance of
available just says Grant application
was unsuccessful funds available to
pursue future discretionary grant
opportunities what does that mean
because apparently we we put this money
out there for something Market
Street uh I don't I can't just CER their
thing so I'd be interested in at least a
a quarterly report on all the projects
that were on hold from the previous
quarter what's the new update um rather
than just dump it in here because I have
no idea what this it says it's on hold
it says the completion date was last
month or
December but the money is still
available so that's the kind of thing
I'm interested in if we put a project on
hold for whatever reason what's the next
step and did status change from the
previous previous report yeah we can U
make that request now the agencies
provide administrative Services if you
look at the the spreadsheet on page one
for instance that's a framework where
the agencies provide information from
the comments over yep everything in the
left side of that comes from the um
statement of Appropriations
system so administrative Services
will'll try to get comments from the
agencies the agencies don't always
provide those but if the based on this
committee wanting to know a certain
status we can certainly ask for that to
be provided and if they can't provide it
we'll ask them to come to the committee
and explain what's going on I I I'm I'm
interested in all the things that were
on hold those are things we either
budgeted for and aren't doing anything
with right now and i' be interested in
KN what the plan is for it um or if it
was on hold last month and it's moving
forward now just let me hey this one
came off hold and it's now so it's
cleaner than I'm looking at this it's
awful lot of columns and numbers right
and um to to this specific example that
you had that was discretionary money
that was put in the capital budget two
cycles ago um so the the department of
Transportation had indicated at that
time that
there's federal government has different
grants popping up and the state's not
eligible for those because they don't
have a matching funding source so there
was a desire at that time for the
capital budget to have some money in it
um I think it was $4 million to to to
try to get those last Capital last time
when the capital budget was being built
the agency reported that those
discretionary um
programs um we didn't win any of those
grants we weren't awarded any of those
grants and so we continued to carry the
money forward so what you with a lot of
these hold projects and and all these
projects when you get the capital budget
itself when you start working on the
capital budget within the house and in
the Senate there's all these laps
extensions in the back which a lot of
these projects that are on hold will
probably be in there and why each one's
on hold varies but we can certainly try
to get some better information thank you
yep Senator gray I'd like to get the
answers to those questions attached to
the minutes so that it will remain in
the so that you know it'll be part of
the record um I think that's a prudent
thing to
do representative F thank you Mr chair I
also have concerns about the hp2
switching from quar uh quarterly to
annual but I have a specific question U
regarding the closed loop referral
contract that you you and I have
discussed going back to last summer
which part of the funding comes out of
the capital projects and specifically
relates the quarterly reporting
guidelines that make mention of when we
get reported on that regarding the
million dollars except other than
capital budget blah blah blah is that is
that s that piece of money in here it
probably would be in the neighborhood of
I don't know 2 and a half or $3 million
because it's half of the actual
contract so so I I don't know the answer
to that we without looking at some of
the detail um I don't what we're showing
is they they they show the appropriation
for the capital projects they don't
necessarily show you what's been
contracted per se they do show you
what's been expended and what's been
encumbered but we wouldn't know was it
due to a contract or was it due to um
actual work that was done by public
works or um we we would have to each
project get the detail related to that
so if there's a specific question well
the frustration I want to just Express
to the committee I'm not sure and I'm
not very familiar with this committee
but I am familiar with this particular
thing um there was this contract which
when through quite a cycle I won't go
through all the details back to the you
know the co times and was finally let
last year after like three efforts um
but the interesting thing about it it
was only maybe six S8 millionar in DHHS
however a big piece of that came out of
a capital projects budget Medicaid
budget from four years ago uh from two
years ago from the last uh term another
big piece of it came out of another
large piece a different place and
another large another half million
dollars came out of Veterans Affair
military something veterans home I guess
maybe it was so I'm concerned that these
especially DHHS but maybe it's a general
a more General thing that contracts are
getting let and the legislator is never
hearing about them this one was never
heard in the legislature house or Senate
in any of the presentations that were
given either the capital projects
committee or to DHHS where I was which I
was serving that finance committee for a
number of six years so I just wanted to
find out make make people aware there's
an issue here that I'd like to be able
representative eel well as long as we're
on the subject of of projects on hold I
would say six to eight years ago there
was money appropriated for upgrading the
parking lot at Sunapee State Beach um
and it's funny I had several
constituents call me about this uh in
the last couple of weeks and I see it
right here it says no info on Project
list for
this so maybe you could inquire we can
and and that comment would be because
the agency didn't respond back to
administrative Services I know I know
which is even more concerning thank
you Mr Shay I think we uh as a committee
we've noticed that having this quarterly
report go to a annual report would not
be in our best interests so I don't know
how we have to work around the fact that
the governor wants it annually because
we I think would certainly be better
served having this report
quarterly so a suggestion I might make
is that um the chair of this committee
could let the chair of Finance who also
serves on this committee know that you
would like a house bill two amendment to
remove that section and our office could
assist the chair with
that represent wer did you hear that
thumbs up thumbs up for the record from
representative
W Mr chair and it is going to division
one so we have some control over the
operation up to up to a point any other
questions
representative
Edgar uh thank you Mr chair said eil
again representative
Edgar yeah I um the question I have it's
a general one and uh it it has to do
with Appropriations that we got and
money we were promised from the federal
government I just want to know if in
fact anything that we've been planning
to use is being withdrawn and if any is
withdrawn I we I think I'd like to be
notified we committee notified about it
right
away we haven't been made aware that
there's any projects in Jeopardy at this
time but as we get information we would
certainly share with the committee thank
you represent I'm sorry Senator gray
close enough you
know um the committee does have the
ability to for any of the Departments
that are not not providing responses for
the minutes of this or for this report
to ask them to attend and provide that
input in person okay and that is usually
a very good incentive for them to
actually provide the report ahead of
time so um again as as the chair and you
know for our staff uh I think that that
should be the policy of this committee
is that if there is a Department that
has not provided input that they be
asked to attend and explain duly
noted if I might just um piggyback on
that comment it that's true for any
project this committee can bring any
agency into this meeting at any time to
get an update or ask questions about any
project you might be interested in so
for instance if Senator Waters wasn't
satisfied with the responses I was able
to get at the next meeting we could ask
those agencies to come in and be ready
to explain expl what's going on we've
done that with um the Hatchery we've
done it with other projects in the past
the um um Environmental Services uh One
Stop has come in a couple of times to
explain what their status is of that
project so if this Committee just has a
desire to bring a certain project before
it and have the agency explain it that
that can happen well before the
quarterly reports come to you so I just
wanted to make that very clear and we're
happy to invite them for you thank you
Senator Waters thank you Mr chairman um
I had a question around the uh $25
million design build limits for the
do and there's that's the maximum that
they can do a design build on and I was
trying to look in statute as to when
that number had been set and so would it
be um possible to to inquire with
DOT um as to whether or not with
inflation and everything else it might
make sense to increase that amount and I
don't you know I don't know whether you
know whether you have any thoughts about
that but I I don't that would be
certainly a question we wish we would
ask do in terms of the size of the
projects and the scope of projects that
they deal with if that $25 million
causes any um delays or or barriers to
getting projects done um but certainly
happy to reach out to do and find out
thank you Mr chairman any other
questions representative wer when we uh
last budget we talked about putting 40
million aside for 10 years so we'd have
400 million to build a new
prison I don't remember whether that was
in the capital budget or the regular
budget do you regular is a regular
budget I think that was in the regular
budget all right because it the governor
leaves it
out thank you Mr
Shay so right now the Department of
Corrections has $50 million to um use to
to design and and get an architectural
schematic of the potential future prison
um they're using the first $10 million I
believe to to make sure that the
property um behind the women's prison is
is uh feasible for putting the new Men's
prison um and then the other 40 million
that was appropriated to them would be
used to do a um design schematic um that
could be used for bidding purposes I say
that because that there may not be a
need for additional Appropriations this
cycle and maybe that's why it wasn't
included but that would certainly be a
question for the capital uh budget
committee to ask um when they come
before you in the next couple weeks um
in the
house than any other questions
representative eel it's not a question
but it's just a comment when I didn't
see the appropriation for Corrections in
the regular in the operations budget I
did look right away into the capital
budget and there's it's not it's not
there it's just more upkeep right
correct Mr Shay have you got all your
questions and everything lined up so far
that you think you've
got I think so but it looks like Senator
Lang may have something else Senator L
I'm just looking number one this is a
great little hand guide this Capital
this this uh legislative review uh 001
on and this is more comment for my the
finance chairs happen to be sitting in
the room when I look at page 12 and I'm
looking at the use of toll credits
interesting enough this committee's got
to approve any use of toll credits and
I'm thinking about a sound barrier we
talked about last year in a budget
process to use toll credits for the
purchase of a sound barrier and yet in
this under here I'm not sure we could
have done that without approval of this
committee and I guess I'm maybe
asking how do how does that work when it
comes to the budget if someone put
something in the budget for the use of a
toll credit so so toll credits isn't
actual money okay so that just is the
match the soft match to get Federal
matching money so if there was a project
where the FED say it's a you know $100
project it's an 8020 match you can use
toll credits to match $20 $20 of that
100 the state would only get $80 for the
project so you still if there's no
federal money toll credits don't help
you well I got I'm just looking at the
last sentence of that law uh 228 col2 it
says any other use of toll credit shall
require approval of the joint
legislative capital projects overview
committee so they come in as an item to
this committee and and make a request
and and this committee either approves
it or denies
it
yeah representative evil okay so I is
the is the reason that um the governor
has put in her HB to that this report
should be prepared annually instead of
quarterly because of the work that's
involved in preparing it I think the
answer is yes um but I would defer to
the Department of administrative
services but it's a pretty pretty
combersome report and it requires a
couple of their um it's not only their
accounting office but Public Works has
to step in as well as um some
administrative help to well I was just
going to suggest maybe one way of red
ring the workload if we still did want
it quarterly is to make the reporting
level 2 million say instead of 1 million
or raise the threshold I mean that's up
I just thought I would mention it if
that's of Interest so I I think when the
change occurred it was a desire of the
previous committee to maintain the
projects that would show up from the
capital budget and then any of the
add-ons that don't go through the
capital budget um if you I'm not sure
how much work you would save by
increasing it from a million to two
million for those projects that aren't
included in the capital budget um it
might help do on that last page but
they've worked they've worked with um
this committee and administrative
services to basically um generate it
through their system so it's not a ton
of work for them to do this you you were
able to narrow it down for them and took
the workload away when when they met
with this Committee in the fall several
so it's not the change in the statute to
capital projects from capital budget
it's just an overall concern that's
right okay that's
right any other questions regarding our
lengthy informational meeting
here seeing none let's move on to item
eight the date of our next meeting Mr
Shay you have a recommendation please uh
in talking with the chair the the
thought of April 14th or that week
that's a Monday um and possibly June
23rd and the reason those two dates were
picked is that um April 14th would be
after the house completes its budget
process so you should have crossovers
all complete as well as the Senate and
the Senate shouldn't be um too too busy
with all the bills that they're getting
from the house by that point and then
the June 23rd date would be in between
Committee of conferences and the last
session day so those were the two um
if we pick the 23rd I won't be here
that's the legislative Golf Classic
day
okay okay representative sen I'm sorry
Senator Waters yeah just on the 14th uh
Career and Technical advisory committee
meets at 9: so if we had that day we
could meet at 11: or but if I can't be
here I can't be here I made toggle
okay let's the meetings at the this
commit I don't make the decision on the
meeting it would be up to the chair and
the members of the committee correct
well I think we could get a substitute
as long as you're the only one at this
point in time so let's go ahead and
schedule the 14th
then 14th for sure and
correct it's actually not the day after
EAS I believe it's the day after pom
okay
yes and we'll take up the 20 June 23rd
on the 14th we'll see how everybody's
anything else if not I'll look for a
motion to adjourn move moved and
seconded all in favor say
I
opposed motion carries we are adjourned